Wir blicken jetzt auf den europäischen Fußball der Männer. Was ist los in England, Spanien, Italien und Frankreich? Das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit Alexi Menü, Christian Bernhardt, Uli Hebel und Alex Treuker jetzt hier in der Rasenfunk Ligatur. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich grüße meine Runde. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Wir werden keinerlei Zeit verschwenden, sondern wir steigen direkt rein in die Ligen. Christian, du darfst sehr gerne mal anfangen. Was gibt's denn aus der Serie A so zu berichten?
Aber Alexi, ganz kurz, findest du wirklich, dass Mbappé von der Bewertung her, dass man da auch wirklich, womöglich geht er in den Nehme weg? Ich finde, Mbappé hat in seiner Karriere auch schon zu viel geleistet, gerade allein mit der Nationalmannschaft. Er ist nur mit einer Kieße, gar keine Frage. Aber findest du echt, dass man ihn da so auf die Schiene stellen kann, dass er womöglich noch quasi– wie meint er, so größte Verschwendung oder so? Also ich finde, dafür hat er auch schon zu viel geliefert.
Wenn man sein Potenzial sieht, muss einfach viel mehr kommen. Und seit zwei Jahren stagniert er komplett. Hättest du gedacht, dass er mal nach Stockholm geht, weil es dort richtig gute Frauen gibt? Hättest du gedacht, dass er mal nach dem Vollgas geht, weil in den letzten Monaten hätte man nicht gedacht, dass er in diese Spirale reinfällt. Man hat schon gedacht, dass er Top-Profi ist, der alles daran setzt, dass er seine Ziele erreichen kann, wie Ronaldo, wie Messi und nicht wie Neymar. Und das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Aber Paris ist auch eine Stadt, wo man auch gerne nachts unterwegs ist. Und in dieser Spirale ist er leider gefallen. Und in Madrid gibt es auch scheinbar gute Clubs, glaube ich, Alex. Und in diesem Fall ist es sehr schwierig. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich nach Liverpool gehen sollen oder nach Dortmund.
Da gibt es auch gute Clubs, glaube ich, in Liverpool, ne? Dortmund nicht, wahrscheinlich, aber Liverpool schon. Ich will es ja sportlich nur betrachten. Alles andere steht mir…
Aber ich spiele auch eine Rolle. Du kannst das nicht…
Ich kann eine Rolle spielen, klar. Dass er psychologisch nicht frei ist, ich glaube, das siehst du auf dem Platz irgendwie schon. Dass es nicht läuft. Die Gründe, da will ich jetzt nicht spekulieren. Ich will nur das Sportliche bewerten oder analysieren. Und was ich da sehe, ist einfach wirklich gemessen an dem, was er zu leisten im Stande ist, welche Standinge er hat, was man sich von ihm erhofft. Ist das zu wenig? Und die Kritik ist eben enorm groß. Gerade aus dem medialen Real Madrid Lager, weil ja die Medienkonzentration in Madrid die größte ist mit den ganzen Tageszeitungen und Radiosendern und eben auch aus dem Fanlager, was ich da wahrnehme. Die schießen sich auf ihn ein, weil er enorm enttäuscht sportlich. Und darauf wollte ich nur kurz zu sprechen kommen. Uli Schüttel, den kommt. Ja, also bei allen. Er trägt das gar nicht, diese ganze Situation. Braucht Man City noch einen Flügel? Ich habe gehört, Doku unzufrieden und so. Kann er ja in dem Sommer noch fliegen.
Nö, der ist nicht unzufrieden.
Sie sind unzufrieden mit ihm.
Ja, meine ich ja, meine ich ja. Das meine ich.
Der ist 25.
Spielt wie 35.
Ach komm jetzt, hör auf. Also selbst wenn die Karriere jetzt endet, kannst du schon einen Haken dahinter machen und sagen, ja, das war ganz in Ordnung, weil der war schon zwei Weltmeisterschaftsfinals und hat beide entscheidend mitgeprägt.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das Zweite hat er fast allein gewonnen. Also ich finde, also sorry. Da siehst du mal, was die Erwartungshaltung ist, wenn der jetzt so real ist.
Aber das ist ja nicht seine Schuld. Also das eine ist ja, Kritik ist ja immer in Ordnung. Und das habe ich, ich habe ja das Spiel gestern gemacht. Ich habe ihn auch kritisiert. Aber das andere ist, ihn persönlich anzugehen, weil er kann ja nichts dafür für die überzogenen Erwartungshaltungen. Er kann auch nichts dafür, dass die jetzt zufällig einen haben, der ebenfalls von der linken Seite kommt. Und da haben sie jetzt die zwei der fünf besten potenziellen Fußballer.
Bei der Vereinsauswahl könntest du das bedenken, dass auf deiner Position einer ist, der Weltklasse ist und der gesetzt ist.
Ja gut, aber du kommst noch nicht… Also mein's ja… Na, dann geh ich nach Liverpool. Sondern du kommst da hin und sagst, okay, das kriegen wir schon hin. Also es gibt in der Geschichte des Sports mehrere Beispiele, wo man sich schon arrangiert. Und wenn ich Liganeske, es ist nur Liganeske, aber ich hab's gesehen, das Spiel, und da hab ich mir gedacht, ach so, es geht nämlich mit den beiden zusammen. Das könnte sogar ganz schön verheerend werden, wenn es mal geht. Und er ist, wir haben noch nicht mal Dezember. Das sind nicht mal vier Monate. Was ist denn los mit uns allen? Jetzt lass mal ihn halt mal ankommen da. Das ist immer noch ein junger Mann, der wahrscheinlich in den letzten sieben Jahren ist.
Ich bin nicht mehr so jung, der ist schon seit 17 Profi. Du kannst nicht.
Ja, das war eins der hitzigsten Segmente, das wir hier in der Ligatur hatten. Ich kann euch allerdings stand jetzt nicht sagen. Ihr seid schon schlauer als ich, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie viel ihr davon gehört habt. Denn bei mir ist das Internet zusammengebrochen, und zwar komplett. Und deswegen müssen wir leider jetzt auch an dieser Stelle dann die Ligatur beenden. Aber ihr habt ja trotzdem über eine Stunde Content hier bekommen. Und wie ich hörte, hatten die anderen viel Spaß, als ich nicht mit dabei war. Man sieht, das Mbappé-Thema war gar nicht so schlecht gewählt, denn so emotional habe ich uns hier noch nie erlebt. Oh Mann, ich war nicht dabei.
Magst du das nochmal aufmachen hier oder was?
Mbappé, War Street Ronaldinho bei Barca. Aus Ruhlzeichen.
Nein.
Ich sage euch, also ich hoffe so sehr, dass es auf der Aufnahme drauf ist, denn ich will das auch jetzt hören. Ich will hören, über was ihr gesprochen habt. Ich weiß nur, dass ich hier wieder reingekommen bin, in diesem Meeting-Raum, und das war quasi wie, wenn so mehrere, so was im Fight-Club während der Brötchenpause. Alle hängen in den Seilen, alle sind verschwitzt und haben aber so ein Grinsen auf den Lippen. Ja, also ich hoffe, viel davon ist auf der Aufnahme gelandet. Es tut mir leid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. So ist es manchmal auch, dass wir jetzt dann an dieser Stelle diese Ligatur beenden müssen, aber das liegt außerhalb unserer Kraft. Ich danke euch Viren umso mehr, dass ihr euch gestritten und diskutiert habt. Alexi Menü, Christian Bernhardt, Uli Hebel und Alex Treuker. Danke euch, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Und dann danke ich natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr wisst, alles, was ihr hier hört oder nicht gehört habt, ist von euch finanziert. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Ich danke in dieser Folge Paddypie, Mystiken, Lukas, Henne und der blau-gelben Datenwelt. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und es wird im Rasenfunk weitergehen. So ist denn das Internet zulässt. Und dann hört ihr uns auch bald hier wieder in einem Format eurer Wahl. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund und macht es gut.
Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!